Now that we understand the when of
adaptive design, namely the points at
which our UI breaks, let's talk
about the what of adaptive design,
specifically the techniques for
what to fix.
Let's think back to what we wanted to
optimize our UIs for and what we can do.
Filling the width of the screen can
become problematic on wider devices.
This might not optimize for
balance and line length.
There a couple of approaches
we can take to address this.
Firstly, you can show additional
content on the screen.
Instead of just filling the extra space,
we can instead show more content there.
One way to do this is to reveal
previously hidden UI elements.
For example, you might use an off-screen
navigation draw on small devices,
but then pin it on-screen
on larger devices.
We might also divide the available
space to show additional content.
For example, showing a details
page on the same screen as a list
rather than on a completely new screen.
We also might reflow content
on different size screens to
better arrange it.
It this example, we're reflowing
a few things on the larger screen.
Firstly, we switch from
a single column of content
to multiple columns to make better
use of the available space.
Secondly, we're not just
rearranging these content cards,
we're also adjusting their layouts to
better fit with this new arrangement.
Lastly, we tweak the app bar height
when the space is available for
a more balanced, branded appearance.
We can also use this reflow technique
in different orientations on the same
device.
In this example,
a portrait layout places an image with
a set aspect ratio above some text.
Now using the same layout
in landscape would likely
fill the entire screen with an image and
push the text down below the fold.
A better approach would be
to reflow the content so
that it's horizontally stacked
instead of vertically,
allowing you to see both the image and
the text together.
Notice that we're also reflowing
the FAP to a more appropriate position
for this layout.
If you don't have more
content to show on-screen,
then you can expand
the content up to a point, and
then introduce margins to constrain
it from growing too wide.
This works extremely well
with a paper metaphor, where
you can use a paper surface which has a
maximum width to constrain the content.
This technique can also work
great if you have rich imagery,
such as a full bleed background,
which you can put behind the content and
layer a service on top of it.
This can create an extremely
immersive experience.